il paraît qu'il ya une compétition chez
les leaders occidentaux qui va dissuader
vladimir poutine d'attaqué l'ukraine
menaces proférées sanctions agitée
maintenant c'est le tour des visites en
présentiel une semaine avant l'escale à
moscou du chancelier allemand olaf
scholz et emmanuel macron qui vient au
kremlin pour désamorcer la situation en
ukraine et à en croire à bfm et les le
seul en europe à voir à l'orée du
président russe emmanuel macron va donc
tenter de pousser la particularité
française dans le concert international
soutient l'elysée dont le personnel
assure que le président français est
actuellement le seul en europe à pouvoir
conduire une telle initiative auprès de
vladimir poutine l'entourage
présidentiel nous assure en effet qu'au
cours de ces dialogues récent avec
vladimir poutine emmanuel macron a senti
qu'il pourrait avoir l'oreille de son
interlocuteur en rouvrant le chapitre du
dombass à quelques mois de la
présidentielle ce serait effectivement
bien d'avoir la fin de la crise en
ukraine sur le cv une source élyséenne
de retorse confie que le but de la
visite serait de négocier pour que le
dispositif militaire russes soient
allégées et soit un sujet ou en menaçant
le président français emmanuel macron se
rendra lundi à moscou avec l'intention
de négocier un allègement du dispositif
militaire à la frontière ukrainienne et
de consolider les avancées obtenues lors
des discussions en format normandie sauf
que la préoccupation majeure pour la
russie et ça a été répété à maintes
reprises l expansion de l'otan vers
l'est le déploiement des armes
offensives et des militaires étrangers à
quelques kilomètres de la frontière
russe sous prétexte de la prétendue
menace russe qui planerait sur son
territoire le cren croule déjà sous
toutes sortes d'équipements militaires
ce qui suscite évidemment l'inquiétude
de la russie qu'ils appellent un vin
pour l'instant au respect des accords de
misc et il faut rappeler que ces accords
prévoient de 10 militariser la zone de
conflit en retirant du territoire
ukrainien le matériel militaire les
forces armées et les combattants
étrangers -sur d'homos coach et
je pense qu'au lieu de menacer ainsi
sans fondement il vaudrait mieux que nos
collègues européens s'attèlent à leurs
responsabilités direct la france dans ce
cas avec l'allemagne bien sûr doit
forcer kiev à respecter les accords de
minsk en l'empêchant de détourner
l'attention comme ils cherchent à le
faire en utilisant comme écran de fumée
l'accusation visant la russie selon
laquelle nous exacerbe on l'escaladent
et sommes sur le point de conquérir
tantôt tout le donbass tantôt une partie
du donbass tantôt toute l'ukraine
mais la diplomatie française semble
préférer proféré des menaces à l'égard
de la russie
nous sommes déterminés à mener ce
dialogue jusqu'au bout pour mettre le
président poutine devant ses
responsabilités
toute atteinte nouvelle à l'intégrité
territoriale de l'ukraine aura des
conséquences massive on ne peut pas être
plus clair ma collègue allemande a dit
pas un pas de plus je fais mienne cette
expression ce type de menace et
avertissements alors que jean yves le
drian reconnaît lui-même que la france
n'a pas d'informations sur l'imminence
d'invasion russe
la maison blanche estime qu'une action
militaire russe en ukraine est possible
en février c'est à dire à partir de la
semaine prochaine partagez vous cette
éventualité je n'ai pas connaissance
qu'une décision russe a été prise en ce
sens par le président poutine nous avons
bien dû avec l'article retirer du
bloomberg intitulé la russie en veille
l'ukraine que tout est prêt pour couvrir
cette offensive russe dans la date est
tout le temps repoussé pour une raison
inconnue les accusations de provocations
répétées de la russie à l'égard de
l'ukraine n'ont de cesse côté américain
emmanuel macron tout en ayant leur et de
vladimir poutine sera-t-il capable
d'entendre la position russe